jens stoltenberg le super général de
l'otan
forme une seule pour les minimes aux as
40 blue toad à musique
veillon brutale et wichita n'auront que
l'otan et le monde entier condamne des
sceaux est mêlé à gâcher l'avenir
agression militaire en europe depuis des
décennies de 6 g villes sont assiégées
des écoles des hôpitaux des immeubles
sont bombardées
au classement est
acquis grâce à
un site nucléaire et de nombreux civils
ont été tués
dans les jours à venir
la situation risque de s'aggraver avec
davantage de morts de souffrance stocks
et de destruction
à ce rush ressort que les forces russes
amène des armes plus lourdes
les attaques risquent de continuer dans
le pays meeting day lors de notre
réunion aujourd'hui
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
l'ukraine s'est adressé à ses homologues
de l'otan des choses a ajouté abdi
prospects nous avons exprimé notre
solidarité notre respect pour le courage
du peuple ukrainien et de ses forces
armées we had world format nous avions
mis en garde depuis des mois le
président poutine souhaité envahir
l'ukraine et dragin si les alliés de
l'otan ont redoublé d'efforts pour
trouver une solution diplomatique at the
same time we might clé nous avons dit
dans le même temps que la russie perd et
un prix très élevé pour
une agression contre l'ukraine et la
russie paix ce prix aujourd'hui
preston put in the world c'est la guerre
du président poutine
une guerre qu'il a choisi planifié games
tri qu'ils mènent contre un pays
pacifique oui cros en poste un peu
d'aplomb le président position à arrêter
cette guerre immédiatement jo a
retiré toutes ses forces d'ukraine deux
sans condition aung est riche et à
s'engager dans une vraie diplomatie dès
maintenant
les alliés de l'otan ont renforcé leur
soutien pour l'ukraine en aidant à
défendre le droit à la légitime défense
tel que prévu par la charte de l'onu
aujourd'hui les ministres ont proposé
une réponse immédiate à la crise et nous
sommes concentrés sur les conséquences à
plus long terme pour la sécurité
européenne
nous avons renforcé nos forces de
dissuasion sur terre dans les airs et
dans la mer les alliés d'amérique du
nord et d'europe ont envoyé des milliers
de soldats au flanc est de l'alliance
nous nous déployons la force de réponse
de l'otan pour la première fois nous
avons plus de 130 qui sont déjà en état
d'alerté élevée et plus de 200 navires
du nord jusqu'à la méditerranée
tu nous continuerons à faire ce qui est
nécessaire pour protéger et défendre
chaque centimètre carré de l'alliance
l'otan est une alliance défensive
ce qui notre tâche est de
se préserver nos trente ans nation nous
ne sommes pas partie au conflit
nous avons une responsabilité de nous
assurer qu'il n'y ait pas d'escaladé et
que le conflit s'étende au-delà de
l'ukraine car cela serait encore plus
dévastateurs et dangereux avec encore
plus de souffrance humaine
l'otan ne cherche pas à faire la guerre
contre la russie
les ambitions du kremlin sont de recréer
une sphère d'influencé
et de nier aux autres pays le la
possibilité de choisir leur voie donc
les ministres ont déterminé ce comment
aider les pays en risque notamment la
géorgie la bosnie herzégovine
l'agression de la russie a créé une
nouvelle normalité pour notre sécurité
ou les principes fondamentaux sont
contestés avec l' usage de la force
et nous sommes face à la menace de
conflit pour les années à venir et il y
a beaucoup qui est en jeu comment nous
organisons la réponse entre les états si
les démocrates ou les autocrates
gagneront et enfin quel type de monde
nous souhaitons avoir ministre ont
considéré que la relation avec la russie
avait changé et pour longtemps mais nous
sommes attachés à garder une chance pour
la diplomatie et la réduction et la
désescalade pour éviter toute escalade
plus d'incompréhension ou mauvaise
interprétation
il ya une leçon à tirer de cette crise
de
d'avoir les états unis l'europe ensemble
dans l'otan en solidarité stratégique
pour préserver nos nations
aujourd'hui aucun pays ni continent ne
peut être seul le président poutine n'a
pas réussi à nous diviser l'otan est
davantage unis déterminée est plus forte
que jamais nous travaillons aussi avec
nos partenaires
aujourd'hui nous avions l'union
européenne la finlande et la suède sont
réponse à l'agression de la russie nous
avons décidé de renforcer notre
coordination et de partager nos
informations avec la suède et la
finlande les deux pays font désormais
partie de toutes les consultations de
l'otan sur la crise 17 nuls cet après
midi
je rejoindrai une réunion des ministres
des affaires étrangères de lieux pour
apporter notre réponse et je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
quelles sont les options envisagées pour
aider des pays tels que la géorgie et la
bosnie herzégovine
deuxième est ce que les alliés ont
discuté du soutien militaire
supplémentaire qui pouvaient être
apportées
et quel est le problème avec les no fly
zone dont on a parlé ce matin
le temps à apporter une aide et continue
à le faire à la géorgie la bosnie
herzégovine et d'autres partenaires
depuis des années nous les avons élevé
avec notre renforcement des capacités
nous réforme renforcer leurs
institutions de sécurité avec un centre
de formation en géorgie les exercices
conjoints
et différentes activités avec différents
pays partenaires nous n'avons pas pris
de décision définitive
mais nous savons qu'il faut faire
davantage pour soutenir ces pays il faut
renforcer nos activités
les institutions de sécurité de la
défense les réformes la formation
mais aussi crée davantage d'activité
pour soutenir ces pays ce que nous avons
vu en ukraine
c'est que
ils sont
exposés à davantage de d'intervention de
subversion et d' attaques de la part des
forces armées russes
la fédération de russie
[Musique]
les alliés de l'otan apporte un soutien
à l'ukraine
et de suite des années et il renforce ce
soutien aujourd'hui avec différents
types de soutien
c'est essentiel aujourd'hui pour
l'ukraine
sur la no fly zone
les alliés sont d'accord pour dire ce
qu'il ne faut pas avoir des avions de
l'otan sur l'espace aérien ukrainiens ou
des troupes de l'otan sur le territoire
ukrainien
y at il une preuve qui montre que le
soutien de l'otan et de ses alliés
arrivé en ukraine
est ce que ça va changer la donne
la russie a ralenti dans certains
endroits mais continue à avancer est ce
que l'otan fait quelque chose qui
pourrait inverser la tendance dans cette
bataille
et qu'en est il du site nucléaire en
ukraine
quelles sont les conséquences et ce que
ça change
l'attitude de l'otan quels ont été les
conclusions sur cette question
les actions sur le site nucléaire de la
nuit dernière qui montre le danger de
cette guerre la guerre est dangereuse
et d'avoir des opérations militaires des
conflits autour d'un site nucléaire
renforce ce danger
il est donc d'autant plus important que
le président poutine
mettre un terme à cette guerre et retire
toutes les troupes russes d'ukraine
et s'engagent dans
des efforts diplomatiques tous de bonne
foi voilà le message des ministres
aujourd'hui
et c'est soutenu
par l'idée qu' il ya un risque d'une
catastrophe nucléaire à cause de cette
guerre
[Musique]
sur les munitions militaires en ukraine
le président poutine a sous-estimé la
force des forces armées ukrainiennes qui
ont pu repousser et ralentir l'avancée
russes et ça c'est le résultat du
courage des forces armées ukrainiennes
avant tout et du soutien du courage du
peuple ukrainien et de leur leader avec
zelensky qui renforce le moral des
troupes ukrainienne et du peuple
les alliés de l'otan se sont formées ce
sont du prêt qui s'y former et équiper
les les ukrainiens depuis 2014
les états unis le royaume uni le canada
en particulier mais aussi la turquie ont
fourni des équipements
une aide militaire
nous avons formé des dizaines de
milliers de forces du craignent haine
qui sont aujourd'hui sur le front
donc ce soutien a finalement été crucial
pour renforcer l'armée ukrainienne et
aujourd'hui nous renforçons le soutien
avec davantage d'approvisionnement
par rapport à la situation en 2014 pour
l'armée ukrainienne la formation fournie
par les alliés de l'otan disent
équipements depuis ont permis
d'améliorer la formation l'équipement et
le commandement et la force des armes et
craignait c'est pour cette raison que
elle est capable de repousser l'invasion
j'ai une question concernant
une qui a déjà été posée le général
breedlove
expliqué que l'otan et les états unis
doivent
fournir dès que possible une aide à
l'ukraine et de fermer
partiellement sur des raisons
humanitaires le ciel ukrainien tous les
ukrainiens demande cela est ce que vous
pensez qu'à un moment les alliés
pourraient réviser leur position combien
de temps cela prendra est ce qu'il y
aura suffisamment
d'ukraine qui auraient été détruits par
pout l'air
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en ukraine
et ce terrible
douloureuse ou des souffrances humaines
des destructions se passe à une échelle
que nous n'avions pas vu depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale
et je salue le courage du peuple
ukrainien ce qui a su faire face h à
l'invasion russe
et aux forces de poutine
c'est pour cette raison que nous
renforçons notre soutien
et que les alliés de l'otan
ont adopté les sanctions les plus
lourdes
et que nous mobilisons le soutien du
monde entier pour condamner la russie et
appelé le président poutine à mettre un
terme à cette guerre
notre responsabilité en tant qu'alliée
de l'otan c'est d'empêcher que cette
guerre
s'entraîne dans une escalade qui dépasse
l'ukraine ce serait encore plus
dangereux
dévastateur
et coûterait encore plus de souffrance
humaine
il n'allons pas entrer en ukraine que ni
sur le terrain ni dans l'espace aérien
il promet
mettre en oeuvre une no fly zone s'est
envoyé des avions de chasse de l'otan
dans l'ukraine en imposant cette no fly
zone en abattant des avions russes nous
comprenons le désespoir
si nous faisons cela nous arriverons
avec potentiellement une guerre totale
en europe qui toucherait beaucoup plus
de pays et qui entraînerait beaucoup
plus de souffrance humaine voilà
pourquoi si nous prenons cette décision
douloureuse d'imposer des sanctions
lourdes d'apporter un soutien renforcé
et significatif
songeait impliqué les forces de l'otan
directement dans le conflit en ukraine
ni sur le terrain ni
dans l'espace aérien
vous avez dit que l'objectif était de
faire en sorte que poutine retire ses
troupes sans condition et s'ils
n'écoutent pas
y at il une ouverture pour des
négociations
et si les sanctions ne lui permettent
pas de se retirer y at il une stratégie
de sortie
nous imposons
un sou très élevé pour la russie comme
nous l'avions dit
que nous avions dû président soutient
que s'il envahissent et l'ukraine il y
aurait des coûts
très élevés à payer c'est ce que nous
faisons avec des sanctions sans
précédent bien sûr ça aura des
conséquences à long terme qui se feront
sentir petit absolue
l'aide humanitaire financière et
militaire que nous apportons à l'ukraine
pour les aider à résister à l'invasion
russe
et aux côtés du monde entier de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu si nous
appelons la russie à s'engager dans des
efforts diplomatiques
à chercher une sortie diplomatique mais
la russie doit donc
s'engager dans des efforts diplomatiques
de bonne foi et la russie n'a pas fait
jusqu'ici le minimum serait de trouver
un accord pour des couloirs humanitaires
[Musique]
afin de faire sortir les civils et
d'apporter une aide humanitaire j'espère
que cela pourrait être une étape
préalable
et je salue tout effort visant à trouver
un accord sur le soutien humanitaire
quelques jours
en bulgarie
il était question d'utiliser des
aéroports et des avions de chasse en
bulgarie pour faire la sq ont monté ce
qu'a dit le ministre des affaires
étrangères les tons qui a dit que l'otan
devait considérer toutes les options
nous avons une réunion avec les
ministres des affaires étrangères
aujourd'hui pour le sommet de l'otan
vendredi
dans ces deux réunions j'ai dit
clairement qu'il faut soutenir l'ukraine
j'ai apporté une aide militaire
différents types dead mais que nous ne
participerons pas au conflit c'est la
position de l'otan
j'envoie ce message
je pense que si l'otan s'implique
directement dans le conflit il y aura
encore plus de souffrance humaine de
civil tué
c'est pourquoi
nous devons renforcer notre soutien
imposer des sanctions lourdes appelé la
russie à s'engager dans une solution
diplomatique ou politique et ne pas
impliquer l'otan notre responsabilité
de protéger de défendre un milliard de
personnes qui vivent dans 30 pays alliés
c'est ce que nous faisons renforçant la
présence de l'otan dans le flanc est
avec nos forces de réponse manouche ne
sauront pas partie au conflit entre
l'ukraine entre l'ukraine et la russie
oui j'ai rencontré le président dawda
récemment nous avons parlé du tout
d'aspect lie à l'invasion brutale russe
de l'ukraine devant vous les
déclarations
du président dawda
que la pologne souhaitait envoyer un
avion vers l'ukraine
le ministre le son a dit qu'il fallait
arriver à une mission total de défense y
at il eu une discussion pour envoyer
davantage de soldats en plus de celles
que vous avez déployés ces dernières
semaines vous avez parlé d'une nouvelle
normalité
certains déploiements doivent-ils
devenir permanent
il faut faire la distinction entre la
réponse immédiate de l'otan et
l'adaptation à plus long terme
du flan est pour la réponse immédiate
nous avons déjà renforcé largement notre
présence avec 200 navires une or jusqu'à
la méditerranée
130 avions en alerte élevée et des
milliers de soldats supplémentaires
je me suis rendu juste devant eux
[Musique]
en roumanie pour rencontrer des soldats
allemands et d'autres je les ai
rencontrés en estonie et en pologne
voilà notre réponse immédiate nous
ferons ce qui est nécessaire pour
protéger les alliés de l'otan et nous
renforcerons cette présence inné c'est
ça dans le même temps aujourd'hui nous
avons commencé la réunion
en nous concentrant sur les changements
à plus long terme de notre présence
notre posture de dissuasion
dans l'alliance et en particulier à
l'est
aujourd'hui nous avons une présence
un lest
avons des groupes de bataillon dans les
pays de la baltique en pologne ainsi
qu'en roumanie ce et dans le sud-est
nous envisageons sérieusement
de renforcer très fortement cette
présence avec davantage de soldats
de défense aérienne
de dissuasion par la défense non
seulement en envoyant un message de
présence
certains ministres l'on dit aujourd'hui
il ya une différence entre la dissuasion
par la présence ou par la défense
nous avons lancé cette discussion
nous aurons une réunion des ministres de
la défense le 16 mars
il y aura davantage de stages
nous appuieront notre décision sur les
conseils
commandant militaire et nous prendrons
une décision
nous avons un peu de temps pour
réfléchir à cette position à plus long
terme
car il faut une réponse immédiate et
nous avons consolidé le flanc est
nous comprenons qu'il y aura aucun
pilote et avions en ukraine de l'otan il
ya une demande du président ukrainien
récemment
pour vendre ou transférer des avions aux
forces armées ukrainiennes
cela est il possible dans le cadre
de l'appui technique et général
par ailleurs
nous avons aujourd'hui un bombardement
sans distinction des villes ukrainiennes
y compris
avec des bombes à vide
dans des zones résidentielles
est ce que l'otan pourrait au moins
réunir des informations concernant les
crimes de la russie en ukraine
actuellement
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine est
flagrante c'est une violation du droit
international
avec l'utilisation de
bombes à sous-munitions
d'autres armes
viole le droit international
et les partenaires et alliés de l'otan
réuni des informations et suivent ce
qu'il se passe en ukraine je salue
également la décision de la cour pénale
internationale pour ouvrir une enquête
nous devons nous assurer que le
président poutine et le président du
bélarus
soit tenu responsable de ce qu'il
commette la brutalité et l'inhumanité la
violation du droit international ou
devons nous assurer que la cpi
s'intéresse à cette question et je salue
donc la décision prise par cette
organisation
les alliés de l'otan apporte différents
types d' aide militaire je ne vais pas
entrer dans les détails sur ce soutien
on est les alliés fournissent de
nombreux différents types de soutiens
publics
nous avions fourni des armes anti chars
des missiles anti aériens
et d'autres types de soutien mais je ne
vais pas vous donner les détails
maintenant
il ya un risque pour la bosnie et la
géorgie y at il une menace d'invasion
concrètes qu'en est il de la moldavie y
at-il un risque accru
ce sont différents pays qui sont face à
différents risques et défis
mais ces pays entend commun que nous
avons vu la russie essayé
d'exercer son pouvoir pour intimider ses
paiements notamment à part la subversion
l'ingérence dans les processus
politiques intérieures ou par l'invasion
militaire la géorgie a été envahi par la
russie
les troupes russes
contrôlent encore une partie de la
géorgie
avec l'abkhazie et l'ossétie en moldavie
il y a des troupes russes sans le
consentement du gouvernement
[Musique]
deux modes d'avis
en bosnie-herzégovine
la situation est fragile et
instable
qui elle est explosive et cela menace
l'unité du pays
même avant l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
ces pays étaient face à des défis large
notamment infligé par la russie mais le
risque a augmenté
[Musique]
nous devons donc
renforcer notre soutien et avoir une
discussion sérieuse au sein de l'otan
pour consolider ces pays face aux
menaces russe
il est représentant de l'otan ont dit
par le passé que l'alliance était prête
à discuter des questions de stabilité
avec la russie cependant la question du
contrôle des armes des armements de
merger priorité le niveau de tension
augmenté après
l'augmentation de
duos de la situation actuelle j at il
une discussion sur cette question et
pourquoi est ce que l'alliance a fourni
des armes modernes à l'ukraine que le
gouvernement demandait
tout d'abord comme je vais dit les
alliés de l'otan ont fourni à l'ukraine
des armes depuis 2014 ils les alliés de
l'otan ont formé de milliers de soldats
ukrainiens qui sont sur le front et nous
les avons aidés à faire face
à l'invasion sans formation sans
équipement
les les armées ukrainiennes aurait été
bien moins capables de faire face à
l'invasion russe
le courage des forces armées
ukrainiennes et le facteur déterminant
mais la formation et les équipements ont
été essentiels
ça comprend
d'autres types d'études assistant sur
les questions stratégiques
nous nous avons tendu la main à la
russie avant l'invasion nous avions des
renseignements
qu'ils envisageaient ce qui allait se
passer maintenant il faut comprendre que
depuis des mois les alliés de l'otan
mettent en garde contre
le fait que la russie a massé des forces
et prévoyez une invasion nous avons dans
le même temps intensifier nos efforts
pour
engager la russie dans un dialogue
diplomatique pour empêcher cette
invasion le président poutine a décidé
de ne pas chercher de solutions
politiques mais d'envahir d'utiliser la
force militaire
nous soutenons toujours une solution
politique mais nous sommes aujourd'hui
face à la russie qui utilise la force
militaire
pour chercher à détruire un état
souverain indépendant en europe les
états unis et la russie quid se sont mis
d'accord récemment pour
et limité pour prolonger la cornue start
jeu pour limiter les ogives sur les
systèmes à longue portée nous croyons
dans le contrôle des armes mais si l'on
veut avoir un renforcement de
l'architecturé de ce contrôle il faut
que la russie ne tue pas et nos valises
pas
il faut que moscou
s'engagent dans des efforts politiques
pour réduire les tensions
et consolider le contrôle des armements
notre question sur les armes mais c'est
une question fondamentale maintenant
vous le savez l'union européenne
finance un demi milliard est
donné le coordinateur alors
vu que c'était un voyou pourrait
attaquer n'importe quel pays maintenant
est ce que l'otan ne devrait pas créer
une nouvelle structure permanente ou en
tout cas
désigne un allié sûr bête une rotation
pour assurer la coordination des
transferts d'armes des alliés afin
d'anticiper
une nouvelle crise je ne pense pas à des
consultations haddock ni à des fonds
d'affectation spéciale mais à quelque
chose à caractère permanent
et bien il faut rester ouvert par
rapport aux structures pour soutenir les
partenaires et les pays
sur lesquels pèse un risque mais il faut
une approche pragmatique est ce que nous
avons vu en ukraine par exemple c'est
que l'otan fournit assez retient soutien
et nous avions un bureau à kiev nous
nous sommes concentrés sur la
modernisation du système de défense des
institutions ce qui est logistique cyber
et nous les avons aidés avec des
capacités navales également donc l'otan
en tant qu'institution a fourni une aide
importante à l'ukraine pendant de
nombreuses années
et nous continuons de le faire mais par
ailleurs les alliés à titre individuel
aux fourni
une aide une formation militaire
peu importe comment cela est organisé en
fait pour autant que le pays qui en a
besoin reçoivent le soutien et l'aide
dont il a besoin et au fil des ans
depuis 2014
des milliers de soldats ukrainiens
ont bénéficié d'une formation d'un
entraînements dispensés par des forces
de l'otan par des des forces
d'opérations spéciales ils savent
comment utiliser les équipements et ils
ont été formés à la cyberdéfense
et c'est donc c'est quelque chose que
nous faisons en tant qu'alliance sur
base de nos structures en ou consultants
mais tout cela elle fournit en bilatéral
par les parties parlées les membres de
l'otan notamment les états unis le
royaume uni et le canada
qui ont fourni le gros des équipements
et de l'entraînement et la turquie a
fourni des capacités clés en ce compris
des drones
et certains états baltes ont
fourni un soutien militaire avant
l'invasion depuis l'invasion de nombreux
alliés ont intensifié leurs raids on ne
sait pas très bien si j'ai répondu à
votre question mais il convient d'être
pragmatique s'agissant de la manière
dont nous nous organisons pour autant
que l'otan et les alliés de l'otan sont
en mesure de fournir un soutien aux
partenaires qui en ont besoin merci
cette conférence de presse est terminée